mon nom est fils exploitiez g12 je
pratique leurs acquis depuis l'âge de
cinq ans et le vélo de montagne depuis
l'âge de 7 ans qui développe et que j'ai
une passion pour le sport je suis
persévérant et relever des défis fait
partie de mon quotidien
la présentation c'est utile l'important
support dans la vie des gens
j'ai démontré au lit pliant sasp et
poustis porte sur le plan physique que
sur le plan mental et social
j'aborde le aussi quelques aspects
négatifs à la pratique du sport
ma vie c'est le sport le sport c'est ma
vie donc le but de la présentation si
vous en dire plus aux l'important
support dans la vie des gens saviez vous
que seulement 51 % des jeunes de 5 à 14
ans pratique du sport régulièrement il
saviez vous que dans toutes les
catégories d'âge les hommes soient plus
sportif que les femmes donc à l'aide
d'effets le but de la présentation ci
non seulement vous en dire plus sur
l'importance port mais aussi de vous
sensibiliser à quel impact peut avoir le
sport sur vous si vous en faites ou non
beaucoup me fais c'est que les sports
sands à perdre du poids
j'ai commencé par se fait là parce que
je crois que c'est pas nouveau dans
votre taille comme j'ai dit que le sport
cen-sad a perdu peau perd du coup
ecce terra mais il ya plusieurs
personnes qui pensent que 15 minutes
d'activité physique par jour ça sera
amplement suffisant pour atteindre un
bon régime mais j'ai lu plusieurs
articles
ils m'ont tous démontré qu'il faudrait
couvrir 80 que six kilomètres par jour
pendant un mois
bourges cher à perdre un seul qui lui
colle mon deuxième fait si que le sport
soit tu vas nous faire des amis comme
peuvent moi dès que je suis arrivé à ma
nouvelle école primaire
je me suis toujours inscrit dans
l'option sport hockey et ce qu'est ce
que ça a fait ça m'a aidé à me dégêner
est vendu sa cour d'école je parlais
quasiment à tout le monde donc si
surtout fait d'appliquer un bon esprit
d'équipé donc d'appliquer une bonne
chimie
je prends un exemple d'une chambre qui
avait un match de mon nez et concentrés
et prêts à l'y se défoncer donc le sport
sinon ce
un bon moyen de se faire des amis mais
aussi un bon moyen de découvrir d'autres
côtés d'une personne
donc quand je disais avant match de mon
et concentré si différent de la personne
qui a mis sur une cour dès que mon
troisième fait si qui a pas une
meilleure forme physique le sport ça
peut nous amener plusieurs qualités
comme la persévérance et la discipline
la persévérance je voudrais que moi j'ai
vraiment développer jeunes et dans le
sport parce que moi dès que j'ai
embarqué sur la glace parce que moi je
joue aux quilles je me donnais des
objectifs et je percevrai pour les
attentes
est ce ça a fait que j'ai fait la même
chose et dans d'autres étapes de ma vie
comme mes résultats scolaires
je me donnais l'objectif d'avoir de
meilleures notes donc je persévère et
plus et j'ai étudié plus pour les attend
la discipline je dirais que c'est
vraiment un rendu dans des niveaux de
sport plus compétitif donc commencer
enfin ce qui est six fois par semaine
vous commencez à être disciplinés
appliquer un bon horreur donc comme vous
êtes plus jeunes bien joué j'ai étudiés
tels que vous aussi pourquoi le sport ça
pareil sur vos résultats scolaires et
comme cet adulte ou 6 1 je voudrais
qu'il faut de la discipline
parce que si elle met on vous avait dit
oh god damn vous soyez discipliné à
préparer le rapport aujourd'hui donc les
adultes en podologie spin
donc mon quatrième et dernier fait c'est
que le sport ça nous fait souvent
qu'adeline au programme quand je
prononce pas des problèmes comme un
conflit avec quelqu'un mais plutôt des
problèmes de temps donc des problèmes
qui nous stresse je voudrais que prendre
une heure par jour pour phase i au coeur
ça peut être une très bonne solution
ça peut vous aider à penser à des
solutions dans l'axé décompresser donc
de faire du yoga c'est très bon et pas
seulement yoga juste le fait se donner à
100% dans ce sport d'intensité ça peut
vous aider à oublier tous vos problèmes
juste penser à donner une bonne
performance
j'ai nommé plusieurs avantages mais
malheureusement il ya bien des
désavantages aux sports il vous dirait
qu'ils sont plutôt liées au sport
compétitif
un des désavantages comme j'ai nommé
demande à ma présentation c'est que le
sport ça pas beaucoup de temps avant une
semaine
donc quand vous êtes plus jeune plus de
temps un sport moins tu apprécies dié
donc c'est sûr que le sport ça peu
pareils sur vos résultats scolaires un
autre des avantages si kate est une
personne qui accumule les échecs ça peut
vraiment nourrir son moral ça peut
l'entraîner à s'enfermer dans sa chambre
ça peut nuire à sociale donc l'entraîné
à plus vouloir parler à beaucoup de
monde donc d'accumuler les échecs ça
peut être un gros impact sur une
personne
pour finir je dirai ce que j'en pense
mode sport ben comme beaucoup de
personnes de mon entourage le savent le
sport ça prend place dans ma vie
pour moi il ya que des avantages et ça
m'a vraiment aidé à développer de la
persévérance et la discipline
on est aussi est-ce que je vous avais
dit que le sport c'est ma vie il ma vie
c'est le sport merci